if you're not already building an AI
Focus side hustle you are behind the
curve chat GPT freaked programmers out
in the same way the Ben's motor car
freaked horses out 150 years ago it
could be all hype or it could be a
paradigm shift into the artificial
intelligence age either way if you
listen carefully you can hear a stampede
of developers in the background getting
in on the next technological gold rush
but like I've said before during a gold
rush sell shovels if you want to make
money this video is my free shovel to
you where we'll take a realistic look at
how to build AI driven apps from both
Technical and business perspectives
there's a lot of VC money flowing into
AI startups right now we'll examine them
to see how their attack is implemented
and how they plan on making money and
you might be surprised at how easy it
actually is to build an AI app when
using the right tools the ultimate
shovel salesman is open AI the creators
of chatgpt which is based on an auto
regressive language model called gpt3 or
technically 3.5 by now we all know how
impressive it is but what's crazy is
gpt4s around the corner gpt3 is trained
on an unprecedented 175 billion
parameters but that's absolutely dwarfed
by gpt4 with 100 trillion parameters
maybe we've reached the peak of what is
possible with deep learning and gpt4 is
a nothing Burger openai CEO says you'll
be disappointed but maybe that's what he
wants you to think because he knows the
technological singularity is near in
which all of humanity is enslaved or
exterminated either way the only thing
that really matters in life is that we
make some mother effing money one idea
you might have is to build your own
Superior GPT model but that's an idea I
would describe as complete you're up
against a company with the smartest
people in the world that's received
billions of dollars in funding from
companies like Microsoft if you can't
beat them join them their technology is
available via a paid API and just
recently became available on Azure cloud
and there's all kinds of use cases if
you use your imagination one example is
video tap it which takes a video as an
input and converts it into a blog post
by transcribing it and using AI to
generate headers automatically an app
like this could be accomplished by an
independent developer or small team you
could use openai whisper to do the
transcription GPT to generate the
headers and you could even throw in
something like dolly to generate unique
images for the blog post now I realized
five seconds ago I said you can't
compete with open AI but don't listen to
haters like me GPT is not the only game
in town you have Deep Mind from Google
with other language models like
chinchilla and alphaco that's been out
there winning coding competitions and
there's also open source language models
like Bloom if you have access to a lot
of high quality data it is possible you
could train your own predictive model
then offer it as a service the process
of turning raw data into an actual
deployed machine learning model is
called ml Ops tools on Google cloud like
vertex AI handle every step of the
process they ingest and process data
they train and evaluate models and then
deploy them to serverless infrastructure
where you can actually use them in an
app in addition there are tools like
hugging face that provides ml Ops as a
service but they provide thousands of
Open Source pre-trained models that you
can use as a starting point most
importantly you'll want to get really
good at some kind of a specialized use
case an example that comes to mind is
play.ht which can create custom AI
generated voices they have an entire
fake podcast between Joe Rogan and Steve
Jobs jobs and for all you know my voice
can be entirely AI generated right now
you can clone your own voice it is crazy
good uh it's not my name is Jeff but I
did look into it and it cost tens of
thousands of dollars to get your voice
cloned which is understandable because
there's very few companies that can
actually offer this service at a high
level at least in today's world another
crazy example is bead oven which I'm
using right now to generate this
inappropriately tense background music
it combines generative AI with real
music to create unique music or how
about resume worded a tool that can
analyze your resume and Linkedin profile
if you never learn to read good or write
good AI can now do all the heavy lifting
and I guarantee you there are developers
right now building AI apps that will
help kids cheat on their homework at the
same time other developers are building
tools to prevent AI cheating by using AI
there's a ton of different angles to
make money here no matter what you
decide to build it's a good idea to
build in public which can sometimes make
your business go viral that's exactly
what happened with restorephotos.io it's
a simple next.js app that was launched a
few weeks ago and already has over 40
000 users what I love about it is that
it solves one simple problem you upload
a grainy photo then it uses AI to
restore it to a high resolution photo
the code is all open source and as you
can see here it uses an API called
replicate to perform the image
transformation with an open source
machine learning model in this case the
model is gfpgan but there are many other
models to choose from the key here is to
find a problem then create a no-nonsense
highly focused solution for it then
finally do some kind of tick tock dance
while using it to make it go viral
another potential way to make money is
to slap the label of artificial
intelligence on an existing business
model that already Works we've already
seen many companies do that in recent
years the like McDonald's going fully
automated which is great because it
means no unwanted reproductive fluids in
your Big Mac or like upstart an AI
lending platform that uses machine
learning or a fancy way of doing
statistics to lend money on more factors
than just the credit score its IPO
investors are currently holding the bag
for a 90 loss but its early investors
got rich you could build an app like
this yourself without even using deep
learning you just need like 10 lines of
python code to run a regression on the
input data then boom you're now an AI
lending platform assuming you also own
your own bank the takeaway here is that
you can use the artificial intelligence
label to make your business look
disruptive even if it's running a grip
that's been around forever now if you
really want to make a lot of money don't
look around at other cheap poor people
like yourself instead sell to Enterprise
and government finish this sentence
blank.ai provides a tool that will save
your company 70 per year in blank costs
congratulations you just wrote a pitch
for the next AI unicorn startup the
blank might be something like shipping
Logistics Talent recruitment or business
presentations as is the case with
present.ai this startup will take a
company's branding and marketing assets
and automatically create tons of slide
templates for business presentations I
have no idea what their Tech looks like
under the hood but it looks like a use
case for generative image models or
tools that can take text as a prompt and
return images as a result one of the
most impressive Tools in this space is
mid-journey you can use the beta by
going to their Discord and ask for
something like a business presentation
for my oil and gas company the result
you get back looks like something
produced by a talented human generative
AI is so hot right now but there's just
as much if not more opportunity in
natural language processing another huge
cost for Enterprise is customer support
chat EPT has made it clear that customer
support jobs will largely go to AI in
the coming years however the average
company has no idea how to integrate
this technology into their business move
works is just one of the companies that
is bridging this Gap they build AI chat
Bots that integrate with your entire
Tech stack they can solve problems
faster and cheaper than a human could
ever dream of there are tools like AWS
Lex and Google dialog flow that you can
use to build chat Bots right now they
can handle business Logic on the back
end with web Hooks and can be integrated
with gpt3 to provide unique human-like
interactions as you can see there are
going to be tons of opportunities in the
next few years for ambitious and clever
developers however there is a dark side
to all of this the technology is moving
so fast that an idea that might look
like a guaranteed success today turns
out to be completely obsolete a year
from now in addition the sad reality is
that big Tech is going to absolutely
dominate this space they have all the
data and computing power required to
really push this technology forward it's
really hard for me to compete with my
Intel Pentium processor from my mom's
basement even if you do manage to build
a game changer Zuckerberg is just going
to steal it anyway another Dark Side to
AI is that this technology will likely
be harnessed by scammers it's actually
pretty scary someone could clone my
voice based on all my YouTube videos
then call my Grandma and tell her I got
arrested in Mexico and that she needs to
transfer some Bitcoin over to get me out
not cool to scare my grandma like that
man also at one point or another
everybody has wired money over to their
long-lost Nigerian prince relative only
to be disappointed when that big
inheritance never comes through scams
like this are only going to get better
we can scale them up by using tools like
chat GPT to automatically format letters
in proper English well actually upon
testing I guess scam emails are not
allowed in addition you could even
Target a specific person and combine
their face with some real Nigerian
prince so the target actually sees a
long lost relative with resemblance to
their own face we're entering a Brave
New World where it's going to be very
difficult to distinguish fakery from
reality deep fakes have been around for
a while but they're only going to get
better big companies that have all your
data know everything about you they know
what you read how you write how you look
and how you act and they've been using
that data to serve you advertisements
but nowadays with generative AI they
quite literally have the ability to
become you in the digital sense sounds
creepy but the good news is that we can
use this technology to live forever even
if I get smashed by an elephant or fall
into a volcano I will continue making
these YouTube videos because the
artificial me will be indistinguishable
nay superior to the real me and won't
make silly typos not only will I
continue working but I will continue to
raise my family and the metaverse and
not just my kids but their kids and then
their kids because I will be the Apex
Alpha artificial Grandpa the first of
its kind they could even upload me to a
lifelike robotic doll so my wife and
kids never even know I died that's
actually a great business idea create a
company that clones a person's Persona
uploads it to a doll that is
automatically deployed when that
person's organic form terminates that
may sound crazy but it's within the
realm of possibility in our lifetimes
thanks for watching and I will see you
forever and ever until the end of time